so we're going to talk about state
machines which is a topic that you're
gonna see on many further courses
because state machines model step by
step processes and of course you if you
think about a computation the normal way
you think about it is that it's doing
instructions step by step one after
another until it finally reaches
termination
likewise various digital circuits move
through stages or states until they
produce a final answer so state machines
come up and at least those circumstances
and many others now the general model of
state machine involves the idea that you
can give an input and it responds to
them but we don't really need that for
our purposes so let's look at our
example of a state machine here's maybe
here's a particular simple one this is a
description of a state machine that
counts to 99 so the circles are
indicating what it states are we've
named them from 0 through 99 and then
there's a final state called overflow
and that funny arc is an indication that
if you're about if you're in overflow
mode and you make another step by
following the arc you get back to
overflow mode but if you're in zero you
can make a step to one and if you're in
one you can make a step to two and so on
so starting off at the start state which
is generally indicated by that double
mark so to indicate where to start then
the description of this machine
consistent in complete description is a
set of states which are pictured as 0
through 99 plus overflow a set of
transitions which are indicated by the
arrows which is how one state can move
to another state and the transitions can
be summarized by saying that they're of
the form i to i plus 1 for i between 0
and 99 and then there's a 99 transition
to overflow and once you're an overflow
you stay in overflow so the picture at
the top is saying exactly the same thing
as we've said here in mathematical
notation explicitly describing what the
trends
azar so so this is a machine that if you
really build something that behaved this
way it wouldn't be much use because once
it's overflowed its dead because it
stays there a real machine to be useful
would have a reset transition which took
overflow back to zero but this
illustrates the basic idea so let's look
at a fun example from a die hard movie
my forgotten which one it was but there
was one with Bruce Willis and Samuel
Jackson playing a detective and a friend
that he meets who helps him deal with a
madman as is the case in all these
movies
this time the mad man's name is Simon
and what Simon says to them as they
stand behind the fountain in the park
shown on the previous slide is that on
the fountain there should be two jugs do
you see them a five gallon and a three
gallon fill one of these jugs with
exactly four gallons of water and place
it on the scale and the timer will stop
the timer in the scale are not shown in
that picture but there's a scale and a
timer nearby you must be precise one
ounce more or less will result in
detonation if you're still alive in five
minutes we'll speak okay so let's think
about formalizing this as a state
machine to see what's going on so first
of all to understand the the the
specification informally what there is
is a three gallon jug and a five gallon
jug that is capable of holding water and
an unlimited supply of water that you
can get from the fountain and the basic
moves that you can make so with this
setup the kind of moves that you can
make would be say you fill up the three
gallon jug with water and then you could
pour the three gallon jug into the five
gallon jugs or the three gallon jug was
empty in the five gallon jug you knew
had exactly three gallons in it and then
you can do other things like empty a jug
and fill a jug and empty them into each
other so let's model this as a state
machine and the first decision we need
to make is what's the state going to be
well the state of the obvious model for
the state is the amount
water in each of the jugs so B is the
amount in the big jug and L is the
amount in the little jug and what we
know about BNL is that they're gonna be
some amount between 0 & 5 for B & 0 & 3
for L where but we're gonna quickly
realize that we need them to be integers
but offhand we can allow them to be real
numbers because after all you could just
pour some arbitrary amount of water into
the big jug any amount that will hold
between 0 & 5 although that'll be
dangerous because as soon as you do that
you're gonna lose track of exactly how
much is in there and you won't know when
you have 4 gallons or not
so let's formalize the possible moves
that we can have so first of all the
start state is zero zero because we
start with both jugs empty and then what
are the possible transitions of how
being elmo's well let's see the the fill
the little jug move amounts to saying
that if you have an amount of being big
and Ellen little then you can make a
transition called fill the little jug in
to be in big still unchanged and three
in little 4l less than three I'm gonna
forbid the vacuous move where you the
little jug is already felt full and you
try to fill it that doesn't count so L
has to be less than three you can make
it three by filling the little jug
similarly you can fill the big jug if B
is less than five then you can turn it
into five by filling it and then you can
empty the little jug which is easy if
you go from BL you go to be zero and
likewise you can empty the big jug those
are the easy moves slightly more
complicated move is pour the big jug
into the little jug well if there's no
overflow what that means is that there's
Ellen the little jug and B in the big
jug and after you've poured the big jug
into the little jug there's B plus L in
the in the little one and nothing in the
big one
but let's be careful here about what
exactly we're doing math we're not sort
of we're trying to get away from the
metaphor so what is no overflow means it
simply means that B plus L will fit B
plus L is less than or equal to three
all right what's the other case of
pouring the big jug into the little jug
well that's when
plus L won't fit in which case you pour
into the little jug
it's got L so you pour in three minus L
to fill it up and then what's left in B
is B minus the three ones little L that
you poured so that's the otherwise case
when there is overflow and similarly
there are moves for pouring the little
jug into the big jug so that then is a
formal specification of the die hard
machine and the moves that we're going
to allow now you could allow other moves
like randomly pouring out a little water
or randomly filling up a little water
but if you did that again you'll lose
track of how much water is in the jug so
these are the only safe moves and
they're the only ones we're gonna model
alright so let's go back to Simon's
challenge he wants to disarm the bomb by
getting exactly four gallons of water on
the sky in a jug and measure it on the
scale or things will blow up and how do
you do it well why don't you take a
moment to think about it before I
proceed to the next set of slides or
before you let me proceed but just to
understand the rules again and watch the
work here's how we're gonna start off
with both jugs empty so we start off in
state zero zero and the first move is
gonna be to fill the big jug which takes
us to state five zero where the big jug
has five and the little jug is still
empty then we're gonna pour from the big
into the little so now the little jug
has three we're filling up the little
one
and that leaves two in the big jug now
we're going to empty the little one and
we still have two left in the big one
and now we're gonna pour from the big
one into the little one so the little
one has two gallons and the big one is
empty now we fill the big jug and
there's still two gallons in the little
one and five gallons and the big one now
we pour off from the five gallon jug
into until the one gallon jug is full
that's removing the one gallon that the
three gallon jug still has capacity
or we reduce to full three gallons in
the little jug and four gallons our
target in the big jug and so we've
accomplished it
and we're done so the bomb doesn't go
off all right so the point of this
exercise is really just to practice how
the moves work and what the states are
but the questions I want to raise is
suppose that we want to have a die hard
once in for all scenario in which we're
tired of the remakes of these movies and
we propose that in the next movie that
Simon if he's still around offers an
alternative challenge or instead of a
three gallon and a five gallon jug
there's a three gallon jug an annoying
gallon jug and now the question is can
you get four gallons into the big jug by
pouring back and forth with rules like
these or can't you and can you prove it
well my guess is that you probably can
figure out what's going on because
what's happening is if you start off
with nothing in either jug and you do
these moves of filling up a jug or
pouring one jug into another you'll
discover that the amount of water in any
jug is always divisible by three this is
a preserved invariant any state that you
can get to starting off from zero zero
three will divide the number of gallons
in each jug we could state it this way
there's a property of states property of
B and L which is the state which is that
three divides B that vertical line isn't
is a shorthand for the simple divides so
three divides B or B as a multiple of
three three divides L synonym L is a
multiple of three and the claim is that
that's always gonna be true so in case
that's not obvious you might not have
all the rules in your head but let's
just take a look at one of the more
complicated rules this was the rule
where you're pouring the big jug into
the little jug up till the until the
little jug is full and that transition
is that if you're in state B
you move to be minus three minus L and
three and if you look at this now
clearly if three divides both B and L
both components of the state your ad
then in the new state well three
obviously divides the contents of the
little jug which is three but three also
divides the contents and the big jug
which is a multiple of three namely B
minus three which is a multiple of 3
minus W which is a multiple of three
when you take a linear combination of
multiples of three you get a multiple of
three and you look at all the other
transitions and they check equally well
if you are in a state B L and you move
to a new state B prime L prime if three
divides B in L then three divides B
Prime and L prime so this is what's
called a preserved invariant and of
course the corollary is that in the
die-hard once-and-for-all game with the
three jug three gallon jug and the nine
gallon jug you can't get to any state of
the form 4x because four is not
divisible by three and therefore Bruce
is gonna die now what we've Illustrated
here is an argument that's known as
Floyd's invariant principle and it's
really nothing but induction
reformulated for state machines the
statement of Floyd's invariant principle
is that we're going to define a
preserved invariant is a property of
States and a preserved invariant means
it has the property that if you're in a
state that has property P and it's
possible to make a single transition to
a state R then R will also have property
P this is just like the induction step
you have to prove that p of n implies P
of n plus one so if you have a preserved
invariant then if the property holds at
the start state then it's obvious that
the property will hold for all of the
states that you can possibly get to that
P of R will hold for all reachable
States so you can prove this by
induction on the number of states but I
think it's clear that if you have a
property that you begin with and it
doesn't change making a step it's never
going to
change and that's all that Floyd's
invariant principle states so in
particular since the property P holds in
all reachable states if there is any
final state within which the machine
reaches then P is going to hold in that
state and what we saw was that it said
we're using the word preserved invariant
to distinguish the definition here from
another usage that's co-opted the word
invariant to mean a property that's true
in all states and while it's nice to
know that some property is true in all
states the way you prove that is by
having a preserved invariance so you
want to distinguish the two technically
if you look at this the predicate that's
always false is a preserved invariant
because of the condition as usual the
way implication works if the antecedent
is false then the entire implication is
true so if you're always false then it's
always the case that if false held in a
state which it never does then it has to
hold in any state you can get to so the
that implication is true so just
remember that preserved invariants that
are constantly false exist they are good
preserved invariants but they're not
what other people would call an
invariant we use preserved invariants to
prove that a property is true in all
states it's a methodology so let's do
one more example to wrap this up suppose
I have a robot on a grid and the integer
grid and we can think then of the
coordinates of the integer as a pair the
coordinates of the robot as the
coordinates of the square that it's in a
pair of non-negative integers now the
way this robot can move is it can make a
diagonal move in one step so it can move
one step to the northeast or south east
or north west or southwest and that's it
and the question I want to ask is
suppose you start the robot off at the
origin at 0 0 is there some way that it
can wander around following its moves
and get to a net state where it's moved
1 square over that is it gets to the
square 0 1
and the answer to that is settled again
by a preserved invariant I don't know
whether it's obvious to you yet but it
will be in a moment I'm claiming you
can't get to the square zero one and the
reason is that there's a preserved
invariant of that set of robot moves
namely the sum of the coordinates is
even isn't invariant if the sum of the
coordinates is even it stays even and
why is that well any move and plus or
minus 1/2 the coordinates of both x and
y may be x and y both go up by one in
which case the sum of x and y increases
by two so if it was even it stays even
or they both go down by one or maybe one
goes up and the other goes down in which
case the sum doesn't change in every
case if X plus y was even it stays even
and as a matter of fact if it was odd it
stays odd moves actually preserve the
parity of X plus y but the invariant is
that X plus y is even now what else is
the case well zero zero zero plus zero
is zero which is even and so we're in a
floyd invariant principle case where all
the positions you can get to from the
origin 0 0 which has an even some have
to have an even sum and since 1 plus 0
is odd you can't get to that square 1 0
it's not reachable
so the parity in variant of the
diagonally moving robot will set us up
for an analysis of the 15 puzzle game
that's this logo that we've had on every
slide in 604 2 so far with 6 blank for 2
on the diagonal this is a game where
there are these little numbered slaw as
tiles that slide into the blank square
and the question is how to permute how
to get from one permutation of the
numbers to another and it turns out that
the analysis of that game depends on a
power
in variant reminiscent of a slightly
more sophisticated than the diagonally
moving robot let's look at one more
example of using the invariant to verify
a little algorithm that actually will be
quite important as the course progresses
and that is fast exponentiation so in
this setup a as a real number and B as a
non-negative integer and I want to
compute the beef power of a let's say B
was a hundred and twenty eight and I
want to compute a hundred and twenty
eighth power of some real number a well
I can multiply a by itself one hundred
and twenty seven times that would work
fine but if you think about it
suppose I square a and then I square it
again and I square it again
then in about eight squarings instead of
ninety nine multiplications I'm gonna
get a to the 128th now if B is not a
power of two you adjust it slightly and
using that idea you can compute the beef
power of a much more rapidly than if you
just naively multiply it out B minus one
times so let's look at the pseudo code
for this algorithm here X Y Z in our
temporary registers y&z hold at Y Z and
are all hold integers and X holds this
real number a and you can read the code
if you wish but in fact I'm going to
immediately jump to the slightly more
abstract and easier to understand
version of it as a state machine so what
matters about this fast exponentiation
algorithm as a state machine is that
first of all there are three states two
real numbers and a non-negative integer
and the start state is going to be that
the number a is in the first register or
in the first location first coordinate
of the States one is the real number in
the second coordinate and be the target
exponent is the non-negative integer in
the third component the transitions are
going to be as follows here's a simple
one if I have
Mount X in the first location Y in the
second location C in the third
then if Z is PI F Z is positive and even
then I'm gonna square X leave Y alone
and divide Z by total and that's the new
state that I get at on the other hand if
Z is odd and positive then I'm gonna
square X multiply Y by X and again take
the quotient of Z divides e by 2 ok why
does this state machine come too fast
exponentiation why is it correct and the
insight is that there's a preserved
invariant of this machine and the
preserved invariant is that Y times X to
the Z is always a to the B so let's see
how to verify that that Y X to the Z is
equal to a to the B well let's just look
at maybe the slightly more interesting
of the two transition rules which is
when Z is positive and odd the XYZ state
moves to a new state indicated in green
where the new value of x is x squared
the new value of y is XY and the new
value of Z is Z minus 1 over 2 remember
you went to the quotient of Z divided by
2 and when Z is odd that means the mine
it's literally Z minus 1 over 2 well
they're the new values satisfy the
invariant if I plug in the Green values
of x squared for Y and x/y for X sorry x
squared for X X Y for y and z minus 1
over 2 for Z well let's see what happens
if I take the new value of y which is X
Y and I multiply it by the new value of
x which is x squared raised to the new
value of Z which is Z minus 1 over 2
let's do a little algebraic
simplification of that well the x
squared to the Z minus 1 over 2 becomes
X to the Z minus 1 and I'm just carrying
over the X Y and then that simplifies to
simply Y times
times X to the Z minus 1 or Y X to the Z
which we assumed was equal to a to the B
so sure enough the new values of x y and
z satisfy the invariant it is a
preserved invariant and an even simpler
argument applies to the other transition
when Z is positive and even so we
verified that this is a preserved
invariant now if the start remember we
start off with the real number a and
register X the real number B in Z and
the real number 1 in Y which is the
accumulator and 1 times a to the B is
equal to a to the B so this is a this
preserved invariant is true of the start
State and that means by Floyds invariant
principle that it is true at the final
state if and when the thing stops well
when does this machine stop as long as
he is positive it can keep moving so it
gets stuck when Z is 0 what happens if
it ever gets to Z is 0 if it gets stuck
then the invariant says that Y X to the
0 has to equal to a to the B but of
course Y X to the 0 is nothing but Y and
what we conclude is that sure enough
this machine leaves the desired
exponential value in the register Y
which is where we get the answer and
that's why this algorithm is correct now
another aspect of of what's going on
here is proving that the algorithm does
terminate so let me just say a word that
floyd distinguished sort of these two
aspects of program correctness that
typically come up one is showing that if
you get an answer it's correct and
that's what we just did if this machine
stops if it ever gets to the case where
Z is 0 then Y has the right answer but
we haven't proved that it stops so we've
shown that it's partially correct like a
partial function it might not be defined
everywhere you haven't shown that yet
but when it is the fun it gives the
right answer and the other aspect of
correctness is termination showing in
effect that
function is total that the program
always does stop well in this case there
is an easy way to see why it always
stops because at every transition Z is
being halved or more Z is a non-negative
integer valued variable and since we're
having it or make it even smaller than
half of it and every step it means that
since it starts with the value Z it
can't get smaller more than log to the
base 2 of B times because by then it
would have hit zero and so we can be
sure that this machine makes it most log
to the base 2 of B transitions and then
it has to get stuck at the only place
that it can stuck which is when Z equals
zero and there is a picture of my friend
and early colleague Bob Floyd whom I met
at the very beginning of my career at
Carnegie Mellon University we worked
together for about one year before he
went off to Stanford and you can read
much more about his life in a warm and
and detailed eulogy written by his best
friend Don Knuth Floyd won the Turing
Award and may effort his major
contributions both to program
correctness and to programming language
parsing